security services are still pouring over
the so-called goldmine of information
contained in the Islamic state files
pastor Sky News even as more terror
attacks happen in the thousands of files
are is registration documents for the
new recruits others identify to training
camps for hundreds of Fighters now sky
news can reveal the existence of a
suicide Brigade men who joined up to die
as martyrs the document reveals 123
names may come from a variety of
countries France Germany Spain Tunisia
and Egypt this is one of the files in
this column he's asked what he would
like to do the answer is simple suicide
bomber this is the registration form of
mohamed belkaid he was killed last week
in the first raid in Brussels in Syria
he is likely to have joined the Islamic
state training program based in rakha
Sky News revealed the existence of this
foreigners training camp for fighters to
attack outside Syria and Iraq one of the
things that the movements are interested
in is how we got a candidate who is
willing and able to carry out a suicide
attack and because there's a value of an
that and another issue that they're
interested in it is it could this person
for example operate in the West so how
they got the language skills are they
familiar with the culture have they come
from the particular region because if
they have then their ability to go back
and operate in that same environment
without getting caught it's much greater
than that for example sending somebody
from the Middle East what is interesting
is a number of times that Belgium or
Belgian cities are mentioned we can
reveal that 25 Belgians are identified
in the files there are 48 references to
Belgian nationals within the
registration paperwork and there are 70
references to the country now this will
include sponsors family members and
telephone numbers amongst the Belgians
we can easily identify a mess cot canker
Turan he came from Bruges and crossed
into Syria in March 2014 he died in
Syria
another is red wanna mohammed hey Joey
from Belgium with a basic sharir
education crossing into Syria in
february2014 Cynthia time with us pull
off wat wat a lord he later appeared in
this Islamic state propaganda video on
the right here he died near the city of
d resolve the Sky News has learned that
Islamic state recruits returning to
Europe were trained not just to carry
out attacks but to be trainers as well
raising the specter a further terror
cells the analysis of these files will
take a long time and certainly security
services are gearing up for a long fight
against Islamic state and its terror
gangs Stewart Ramsey Sky News